[Music]
finally tonight there's an opening on
the supreme court and the confirmation
process has certainly changed over the
years antonin scalia was confirmed 98-0
ruth bader ginsburg 96-3 anthony kennedy
97-0 stephen breyer 87-9 even john
roberts was confirmed 78-22
but that's when things began to change
because of who was in the group voting
no joe biden voted no and barack obama
voted no and so did hillary clinton and
dick durbin and chuck schumer and john
kerry the last four democrat nominees
for president voted no
john roberts was unanimously rated well
qualified by the american bar
association not a single dissenting vote
but that wasn't enough for these four
future democrat nominees for president
they opposed john roberts because it was
politically expedient to do so
being fair was hardly a match for their
political ambition
here we go again with biden's first
opening on the high court he says he
wants a supreme court that looks like
america
if that's true it's a brand new position
for him in 1991 joe biden was in the
senate when thurgood marshall retired
from the supreme court and clarence
thomas was nominated to fill vacancy
clarence thomas is black he would have
replaced the only black supreme court
justice
in a country where 13 percent of the
population was black
but joe biden voted no if biden had his
way the supreme court would have been
all white
and that doesn't look like america
joe biden now says he wants a black
female on the high court but he opposed
a black female in 2005. even worse he
used that old jim crow relic called a
filibuster
to try and keep judge janice rogers
brown off the d.c court of appeals and
biden made it clear he would use the
filibuster again
if she were ever nominated for the
supreme court in fact biden quoted
senator robert byrd while he was
opposing a black woman for the highest
echelons of our judiciary
ain't that some irony quoting a former
klansman while you oppose a black
nominee
that doesn't look like america and then
there's miguel estrada in 2001 estrada
who was hispanic was nominated for the
d.c court of appeals he was found well
qualified by the american bar
association but biden and other senate
democrats blocked him
in 2001 13 percent of the country was
hispanic and exactly zero members of the
supreme court were
biden and the democrats did not just
keep a hispanic man off the second
highest court in the country they kept
him off the bench because he was
hispanic
and this from the crowd who now claims
they want the judiciary to look like
america president biden may want the
court to look like america but senator
biden most assuredly
did not
i can't think of anything that looks
more like america than being a mother
while you also excel in your profession
mothers have been balancing work and
home since the dawn of time
if you really want something to look
like america every single one of us was
brought into the world
by a mother
so what could possibly look more like
america than putting a mother on the
high court especially one rated well
qualified by the american bar
association
sandra day o'connor and ruth bader
ginsburg were both mothers but neither
was on the bench in 2020 when amy coney
barrett was nominated
you claim you want the court to look
like america there are 85 million
mothers in this country and not a single
one on the supreme court at that time so
why did every single senate democrat
oppose putting what would have been the
only mother
on the supreme court
joe biden had a chance to make the court
look like america but he refused
he opposed a black man a black woman a
hispanic man and a mother
and all were qualified all would have
made the court more diverse but biden
said no
and now joe biden has promised to make
the next supreme court justice a black
female
americans including a majority of
democrats believe biden should consider
all nominees
so why not look for the most qualified
candidates period mr president
i am fully convinced some of the names
on that list would be black women i can
think of several right now one would be
michelle chiles from south carolina she
can compete no matter the pool of
applicants
the people who know her and work with
her and appear before her
are universal in their praise for her
character and her intelligence and her
work ethic and to meet her she was
elected to a state court judgeship in
south carolina a state hardly known for
quotas or affirmative action
she was elected out of all the
candidates because she was the most
qualified not because she was a black
woman
she was elected by a
republican-dominated legislature another
entity not known for its embrace of
quotas or affirmative action or set
asides
she was later confirmed by a voice vote
by the u.s senate for a federal
judgeship not one single senator opposed
her
among those supporting her included
former senator jim demint who some
consider to be the grandfather of the
tea party movement
i don't think it was quotas or a belief
in affirmative action that motivated
senator dement to support judge michelle
chiles
she was nominated and confirmed because
she was supremely qualified
and this has been borne out by her time
on the federal bench there's a
difference between picking someone who
is supremely qualified and happens to be
black and picking someone because she is
black
all biden had to do was say he was going
to find the most qualified person for
the job period that list would have
undoubtedly included black women and he
could have picked one of those black
women but he didn't do that he wanted to
make a political point he wanted to help
himself and in the process he sent the
wrong message
black women do not need to compete
merely among themselves for one to
prevail they can and should and do
prevail no matter the competition and i
have seen it countless times you should
look for it yourself
joe biden now claims he wants a court
that looks like
america despite the fact that he whiffed
when he could have done that in the past
and in the process he has refused to do
the one thing that looks the very most
like america
pick the most qualified person
i have every confidence that would have
been a black woman
i wish you did too mr president
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kill me and
i'm ainslie earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis